okay so I want to jump into the flash
War Prelude flash annual number one for
those of you guys who don't know when it
comes to comic books annuals kind of
take different forms we've talked about
this before it used to be that annuals
were just kind of there it was just kind
of like a filler story and it was
usually isolated from everything else
that was going on you would have like a
main story arc and then it would get
around to where we have five weeks in a
month instead of four weeks in a month
or something weird along those lines
basically like five Wednesdays rather
you know as opposed to four and they
just kind of need like a filler story
and so what they do is they just throw
in a random you know annual and usually
it's for like up-and-coming writers and
artists uh the ability for those guys to
kind of make their bones show off what
they're capable of and that kind of a
thing but that's really about it what
this does is it actually kind of breaks
that Trend which is something that's
been going on for really a couple
decades if we're going to be honest with
ourselves annuals have really sort of
evolved from like that old hat format to
basically being like you know tied into
a lot of the ongoing stories and this
one really fleshes out or at least
brings us the Prelude to flash war of
course flash War basically being an
event that's going to see all the
flashes quote unquote going to war with
each other but this initially picks up
in the 25th Century after the events of
Running Scared Now for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with that Running
Scared was a story that we did where we
basically dealt with the idea of the
retold origin of eobard Thon of the
reverse flash in a sense that instead of
him just kind of being a guy who
idolizes a Flash and then went back into
the past and realized he was destined to
become reverse flash and it kind of
drove him insane instead it was the idea
that he and Barry shared a very personal
moment when Barry traveled to the 25th
Century and met iobarthon for the first
time and were Barry trained eobar to use
his powers and so on and so forth when
eobard went back to the modern day he
saw Barry sharing that same moment or I
guess went back to the past rather he
saw Barry sharing that same moment with
Wally West and the result was that he
felt betrayed and became a villain but
the fact remains here that in the
aftermath of that story Running Scared
which basically saw Iris West just kind
of like dispersing the atoms of you know
iobar Thon all over the place using some
kind of a ray gun what this did is it
set in motion the idea that people
wanted to know what was going on and
what we ended up having was this group
that was basically kind of tasked with
tracking down Barry basically trying
into the past tracking down Barry and
then quote unquote arresting him and
this group was essentially tasked by
like a masked man we didn't really know
who he was but following this we
actually kind of you know jumped back to
the uh to the Modern Age right now and
basically pick up with a guy called the
top now the top was never a huge
character in the realm of DC Comics uh
he was one of the small time guys the
overall GS is that he could basically
create like these massive bursts of wind
and spin things and so on and so forth
much like a top like like you would
expect with that whole ideology he was a
John Broome Carmine Infantino creation I
think but the whole idea behind this is
that he's just kind of there wreaking
havoc and then that's really about it
and uh the result is that we end up
having you know Barry and uh Wally West
and then the the young New 52 Wally West
they all just kind of team up and they
basically defeat top and then that's
really about it but from here this is
when things really start to focus on
Wally because that's kind of the nature
of this remember when it comes to the to
the classic Wally West the red-haired
Wally West for the most part despite the
fact that he's back in DC rebirth there
hasn't really been a whole lot of time
spared to really deal with like how he's
coping with the situation we've seen
some all little bits here and there we
really saw it a lot in like the DC
Universe rebirth one shot and like the
flash aftermath story but for the most
part A lot of the stories that have been
told by DC regarding you know classic
Wally West have been told in a way that
just kind of acclimates him to going
back to the Titans getting in contacting
him with Barry Allen that kind of a
thing kind of going back to being a
superhero and it's cool because it's
actually just just sort of a slow build
it's a slow burn and that's the best way
to tell stories in my book you know the
best way to tell it is to kind of Let It
Grow organically and when they sit down
at a taco stand Wally kind of like
Harkens back to you know when he was
younger and he used to come here with
Iris West all the time and so it's kind
of cool because it hits back at these
small moments with his character what we
also end up finding out here is that
what Barry Allen had done is that with
the whole scenario with the top where
that battle had basically finished and
then Iris West had seemingly come
running out of nowhere in order to
basically interview Wally interview a
classic Wally West we end up finding out
Barry engineered that he didn't engineer
the actions of the top he basically
tipped off Iris West to what was going
on so that she would show up and she
would confront Wally and the reason why
is you remember Wally's out of time here
to a degree or at least it kind of seems
that way remember when it comes to DC
rebirth the kind of standard chronology
in terms of how most people accept it is
that you had the classic DC timeline and
then you had the events of Flashpoint
and things were supposed to go back to
normal after the events of Flashpoint
but Dr Manhattan stepped in and what it
meant was that Wally West was kind of
Forgotten he was sort of locked in the
speed force and it was a way for DC to
explain why he wasn't there and so with
classic Wally coming back for the most
part everything's different from here
you know from the way he remembers Linda
Park doesn't remember him Iris West
doesn't remember him for the most part
they don't they don't really know each
other and these are pretty big moments
because remember Linda Park was the
girlfriend of Wally West and then
eventually his wife and they had kids
together so when Wally thinks about
Linda Park the Linda Park that he
remembers he remembers a family he
remembers them basically making a life
for themselves settling down that kind
of a thing but when he's thrust into
this current landscape for DC Comics you
know none of this stuff is going on as
it was him trying to deal with things
now where he should actually go through
and talk to Iris and reveal his identity
and tell for everything he knows or he
should go find Linda Park and even if
nothing happens basically say hey look
these are the things that I remember
although that would be kind of creepy
but the bigger picture here and the
bigger gist of this is that Wally kind
of takes it as an affront
now he takes it offensively for a couple
of reasons Wally's coming from the
standpoint of well Iris wouldn't be able
to handle this like if I told Iris
everything that's going on she wouldn't
be able to grasp it and the whole idea
of very is but dude like she destroyed
eobard Thon I promise she can handle
herself like she can handle this whole
situation but for Wally it's not that
simple and even then it's one of those
things where okay even if she could of
what business is it of yours and that
brings in the direct you know
juxtaposition of like Wally versus Barry
the philosophical differences between
the two but it is kind of intriguing
because in this whole conversation that
they have this whole argument that they
have you know they kind of race a little
bit and then they stop you know and
Barry's like hey look man don't make me
Chase you and Wally simply says look if
I wanted to run away from you there's no
way you could stop me and that's true
one thing to keep in mind this is one of
the reasons why a lot of classic fans of
The Flash love classic Wally West is
because when it comes down to like the
hierarchy of the fastest speedsters
Wally West is the fastest flash he's
faster than Barry Allen that's the way
this whole thing with the flash Mythos
works is for a time all you have adware
like these disconnected speedsters he
had like Johnny Chambers and Jesse
Chambers have discovered a formula they
gave him super speed and when they said
the formula they gained their powers he
had Jay Garrick who was exposed to heavy
water or whatever it is and he inhaled
those gases and suddenly he can run at
the speed of sound and then you had Max
Mercury and he had all these different
characters who were able to tap into the
speed force it wasn't or I guess really
gained superpowers it wasn't until
terminal velocity by Mark Wade that they
were all unified that it was all hey
this formula that Johnny and Jesse
Chambers say the heavy water whatever it
was that the Jay Garrick inhaled what it
did is it all allowed them by one one
measure over another to tap into the
speed force and so that's how they all
gain their powers but where Wally West
is the fastest because he directly main
lines the speed force meaning he draws
directly off of it Barry Allen was the
one who made it and so that's how all
these different characters sort of fit
in so it's a pretty cool moment when it
comes down to these characters because
it's just kind of like hey look I don't
necessarily need you anymore because
remember when it comes to Classic Wally
West when he first became the flash
Christ on infinitas happens the story
ends Wally West ages up Barry Allen's
dead and then and he's you know kind of
stuck under Barry's Shadow for a little
while and then under the writing of like
Mark Wade and all those guys you know it
was basically kind of taking him out of
that shadow and making him his own
superhero and so because of that Wally
just kind of grew into his own character
it's really kind of interesting with
regards to this whole like you know
argument between these two guys but the
fact remains when Wally sits down and
kind of thinks about the various people
that might might remember him or don't
really remember him per se the whole
question is who is it that would
remember him of all the people who were
out there who would recall his existence
and he thinks back to a girl by the name
of Francis Kane that he grew up with now
Francis Kane was introduced back in 1982
by Marv Wolfman and George Perez and she
was a Teen Titans character the way this
whole thing worked out is much like
Chris Claremont with the X-Men where he
was just like creating all different
kinds of mutants and then just throwing
him into the stories and seeing how
people responded Wolfman and Perez
during their kind of iconic run on the
Teen Titans had done very much the exact
same thing the idea was just make it
throw it in the story send it out if
fans love it keep it if they don't get
rid of it and so what you end up having
with Francis Kane is she was basically a
girl who you know grew up with Wally she
was his Lana Lang so to speak for those
of you guys who don't know Lana Lang is
basically the girl that like first
realized that Clark Kent had powers
taught him how to use his powers and
really kind of set the stage for Clark
to become Superman later on in addition
to Jonathan and Martha Kent but the
whole idea was that she was alongside
the Teen Titans for a little while uh
she kind of you know worked with the
team but ultimately ended up just kind
of walking away and there was a lot of
romance between herself and Wally West
and in fact ultimately they just kind of
ended up breaking up and going their own
separate ways but there was a point
whereby she was trying I believe she was
trying to find a way to get rid of her
powers or at least like hone her powers
of magnetism or something like that but
she ended up encountering a scientist
who kind of like Twisted her mind and
then she basically developed a split
personality but that's basically what
happens here Wally shows up and then
just kind of starts talking to her and
says hey look I don't know if you know
me I don't know if you're familiar with
me but here's who I am and I remember
you when you were younger and that kind
of a thing and then suddenly she starts
to remember who he is now this works
that goes all the way back to DC
Universe rebirth number one that's how
he came back was going to Barry Allen
you know visiting as many people as he
could anybody that knew him when he was
a superhero and then finally only comes
across Barry and says you have to
remember me and at the last minute Barry
remembers him and Wally West is back so
that's kind of the The Stick of his
character at the moment is he kind of
travels around to people who have
seemingly forgotten him and kind of
quote unquote wakes up their memories
and so it is cool because basically she
recalls everything about them the fact
that they were friends the fact that
they dated for a while there was a
romance and then immediately the magenta
personality kicks in and she loses it
she just starts attacking him with
everything she can get a hold of but it
is funny and it is really intriguing
because it's him kind of having to come
back in and cope with his own demons you
know cope with the mistakes that he made
in the past the kind of things that he
was involved in all that kind of good
stuff for the most part while he wants
to Spill the Beans in truth with her
being a villain she's really the only
one he can really confide in at the
moment or at least feels like he can
confide in Wally West is really just a
prisoner of his own mind he's just kind
of locked in this cycle for himself you
know it's not that he went to Iris and
she rebuked him is that he's afraid to
because maybe she won't remember him and
that's kind of the fearful thing about
this is that if you're Wally West and
you you say okay so like Barry Allen
remembers me and like the Titans
remember me but like Iris West may not
remember me that would be the most
crushing thing because that's his own
that's like one of the closest people
that he has and to suddenly find out
that she doesn't remember anything about
him she doesn't recall him at all it
would be devastating and so it's almost
one of those things where it's easier to
just not ask than to basically get the
worst kind of answer and so what ends up
happening here is where the magenta
personality begins to settle down and
while he's able to kind of talk some
sense back into Francis Kane sort of
bring that Persona back out this brings
her character back and so it really kind
of teases the possibility that things
could go one of two ways if Wally has to
choose between Linda Park and Francis
Kane which one will he choose now
depending on where you stand with the
Flash comics you could go either way
there are people who are classic fans
that are like nope I want to see him
marry Linda Park and I want to see them
have giant Iris West and I want to see
them like as younger kids you know and I
want to see them be like a flash family
again you know classic Wally West fans
would love to see that come back but
then some people are kind of like yeah
but I mean like we've done that dance
before and so that's why people are kind
of curious about they're like well if we
got Francis Kane that's changes
everything because now Wally West has to
do with a girlfriend who's crazy as hell
but like it's also a chick he dated at
one point along the line and so what you
end up having is Wally sort of coming to
grips with things you know is Wally
basically saying look to this point in
my life I have been in this situation
where I am in this you know this this
rebirth landscape it's not the place
that I remember and I've effectively
kind of kept myself shunted off I've
used the events of like fighting
alongside the Titans I've used the
events of fighting alongside the flash
to effectively shy away from that part
of my life and avoid it all and so what
he needs to do at least you know from
his his perspective is to basically sit
down and say I have to come to grips
with where I am right now I have to come
to grips with like where my life is at
the moment the longer he goes without
talking to Linda Park the least likely
the opportunity is that they'll ever get
together because we're talking about you
know something legitimate she'll just
find a guy and eventually settle down
but if Wally West steps in and says hey
look you know let's get a cup of coffee
I really need to talk to you about
something and I know it's going to sound
crazy as hell but hear me out if it
Sparks memories and she remembers who he
is suddenly everything comes rolling
back in again that's the risk it's kind
of like this incoming book adaptation of
the nature of Love sure ask your girl
out get your heart broken and that
happens a thousand times but then you
ask your girl out she says yes and
you're married four years later so you
know it's one of those things where it's
just kind of like you never know how
it's gonna work out you just gotta give
it a shot you gotta throw it out there
and just kind of see what happens and so
where he ultimately kind of you know
goes back to his position and really
kind of says look I gotta go back with
the flash family you know I'm as much a
part of this as Barry Allen as anybody
else we end up jumping back to the 25th
Century and as we go through this we end
up finding out that again this guy is
basically going through and tasking a
group called The Renegades which is kind
of like the 25th Century version of like
the Rogues you've got guys like mirror
Monarch and Commander Colt but where
that group is tasked with going back and
essentially capturing Barry Allen what
we end up finding out is this group has
actually been sent back by Hunter
zolomon and this is cool this is really
interesting because as far as I'm aware
we have not seen Hunter zolomon yet in
DC rebirth and this begs the question
are we gonna go with like his old school
origin where he's basically almost
identical to Barry Allen in the sense
that his parents you know never really
well his person his parents never got
along Barry Allen's parents got along
fine okay so not exactly Blackberry but
Hunter's parents uh didn't really get
along too well it turned out his father
was a serial killer his mom was going to
turn him in the father of Hunter killed
his mom and then he was arrested I guess
he was really killed by the cops when
everything popped off and he refused to
surrender and then basically had his
legs broken and then you know I guess
you know it was paralyzed and then broke
into like the flash Museum and tried to
use a cosmic treadmill and then like it
displaced him from the time from the
timeline we might just do like a
hunter's Autumn and explain video or
something along those lines in
anticipation for Flash War I don't know
okay so we are uh man Flash Forward dude
I'm okay Joshua Williams man Joshua
Williamson all right I already owe Sean
Murphy lunch and I don't see any reason
why we can't bring in bring in Joshua
Williamson
dude Joshua Williamson man have you ever
stop writing the flash I'm gonna be so
pissed his his work on flash is nuts and
this story is no different and here's a
funny thing it's like the culmination of
everything we've been waiting for since
like the beginning of DC rebirth and the
return of classic Wally West it's like
the one thing we've always wanted to see
and there's dude there's so many great
moments of this okay okay so initially
this whole thing picks up with like
flash and Barry going to war right like
they're just kind of like against each
other and it's like well if you're not
gonna help me then you know whatever
like Wally West is kind of freaking out
on him but we're not really given any
context as to why what we end up doing
is kind of jumping back a little bit
about well really about it almost an
hour earlier and uh and just kind of
picking up with with this whole thing
and this is kind of cool because this is
an exchange between Iris West and The
New 52 Wally West but the difference
here is that when it comes to like this
exchange it's different from the other
ones that we've seen because now iris is
totally aware of Wally right like that
was that was a whole thing when Wally
West when classic Wally West first came
back red-haired Wally West when he first
reappeared we knew from just like the
history of DC that like he and Iris have
like a long-standing history because
their family but when he first appeared
he didn't want to like instigate a whole
situation with Iris and like reveal to
her his identity and so on and so forth
and that was just really like
Williamson's way of working into DC
rebirth in the sense that rebirth is
designed to bring back all the old stuff
and work it into all the new stuff and
kind of combine these two elements
together it created this idea that like
classic Wally West was back but we
didn't know how far out his you know his
his role would be and over the course of
The Flash run and really as far as like
the the events and Titans and so on and
so forth we got these little tidbits
we're like little bits of classic Wally
West pass would kind of pop back up
again and so it was kind of cool because
this this scenario is basically like
they're both aware of the idea of like
who classic Wally West is and what's
going on with this guy and so on and so
forth and it's interesting because then
you have like Barry and and Wally who
basically show up having dealt with you
know a a major issue and I've just kind
of like race to this location and it's
one of the funny things because I still
say that Wally West is faster than Barry
but like it's a funny situation right
like because the way they're drawn here
it's awesome it's like it's like it's
like Ryu versus kin like like who's
better in Street Fighter Ryu or Kim I
say Ken because it was like in the Old
School Street Fighter games he was
faster I don't know if he's still faster
now I haven't played Street Fighter in
like 10 years but still like like it's
interesting to me because what this does
is it starts to throw in this idea that
Wally West is getting a little more
extreme in terms of the lengths that he
will go to to try to like bring his pass
back and that works it's not like it's a
sudden shift that came on you know with
like this story it's been building up to
this you know the idea was that when
Wally first came back he was largely
hands off but then he basically like he
met back up with the Titans and they all
remembered who he was and so from there
it was well I wonder who else will
remember who I am and so it really
became more of like a like an obsession
and we get these small things here and
there for example like in this instance
he remembers who iabbard Thon is and
that's really kind of a throwback to the
return of Barry Allen's Story by Mark
Wade you know back in in well really
post 1984 after crisis on infinite Earth
uh The Flash stories were taken up by a
handful of people he had like Mike
Barron and really like Baron's run was
designed to kind of throw Wally in this
situation where he was always under the
shadow of Barry and it was like well
Barry died in crisis on infinite Earth
and now you know I've got to be the new
Flash and man it's just so hard because
I'm trying to live up to the legacy of
Barry but then when Mark Wade took over
Wade's stance was okay let's get this
show on the road because like people are
tired of seeing Wally under the the
shadow of Barry let's actually like make
Wally something cool and that's why Mark
Wade's Flash run is considered to be
like the run of the flash it's
solidified Wally but in one of the
earlier stories I would say the first
major like the first big story that Mark
Wade wrote was the return of of Barry
Allen and it was basically like the
post-crisis on infinite Earth's origin
of eobard Thon the reverse flash and
that's cool because that's what this is
you're no Barry Allen like it's
literally this whole situation playing
out you have like Wally West who is part
of the Justice League you have like a
lot of these really cool moments and
that's the the interesting thing behind
this was like you can tell the Joshua
Williamson is a fan because these are
Throwbacks to things that fans will
remember this is like a love letter to
all the fans of like cry classic Wally
West now at this point we pick up with
the arrival of the Renegades now we
talked about this in like the the
previous Prelude video that we did to
the events of flash War which is
basically that like in the 25th Century
the Rogues aren't really the Rogues like
the Rogues don't really exist anymore
what you have is the Renegades who are
basically like good guys they're they're
more of like a police force of
metahumans but when you're you know
classic Wally West and when you're Barry
Allen and you've never met the Renegades
or at least as far as you're aware
you've never met the Renegades you don't
see them as Renegades you just see them
as like souped-up Rogues and that have
just kind of like changed their name but
they still look the same and that's
exactly how they react and so it's kind
of cool because where Wally West is
somewhat hot-headed Barry kind of steps
in and says no no no we need to kind of
think things through now this is where I
would say Williamson seems to be hitting
more towards the post-crisis uh you know
version of The Flash as opposed to Wally
West when we're talking about you know
2004 2005 2006. and the reason why I say
that is when Wally first became the
flash under like Mike Barron when he
basically stepped away from Kid Flash
and replaced Barry he was a hothead in a
lot of ways but over the writing of Mark
Wade and like through the life
experiences that Wally had he became a
lot more processed he became a lot more
wise this really came as like a
byproduct of not only Linda Park and
Wally's own kids but things like uh
impulse Bart Allen being sent from the
future into the past so Wally could
train him on how to use his powers it
came from wisdom that was imparted by
people like Max Mercury and Jay Garrick
so because the fact that Wally was
surrounded by so many you know
experienced speedsters he really began
to grow into his own and become a lot
more experienced in terms of what it
meant to be a Flash and that you can't
just run into every situation without
really thinking about what's going on
and so that's where I would say this
kind of seems to be a bit of a
alteration from the Wally that we're
used to but it's not a bad thing because
this kind of feeds into the idea that
like Wally isn't really even sure what's
going on in his own life like he's
gaining memories all the time and so
where he remembers Linda Park maybe he
gains a memory later on where Linda Park
died and again it's kind of crazy
because he's basically remembering all
the things as they happen before 2011.
so for the most part we kind of know how
this is going to turn now with regards
to people who have been reading the
flash for quite some time or at least we
have a general idea but that's the
beauty of rebirth is just because we we
believe we know how it's going to turn
out doesn't mean it will turn out that
way now of course Wally's response being
a little more hot-headed is no he takes
Iris anyway and he races off now this is
cool because with this situation you
could look at this and say well iris is
like the one real thing the one real
tangible thing that Wally West remembers
that he can reach out and touch now
because remember he still keeps that
barrier that separation between himself
and Linda because the current day Linda
doesn't know who Wally is now it doesn't
mean that she won't I mean it took Iris
kind of waking up to realize who Barry
was I'm sorry who uh who Wally was and
there's nothing to say that the same
thing won't happen with Linda but we
talked about this in the previous videos
the fear that Wally has with it with
Linda Park is that maybe he'll wake her
up and she'll freak out and leave and
like she'll abandon him she won't
Embrace him with open arms like oh my
God I can't believe I forgot about you
she'll just be like okay this is too
much for me to handle and she'll she'll
leave him and so it'll be like losing
her all over again that's really like
the biggest fear that he deals with the
other half of this and this is one of
the things that I love about Iris in the
comics is she's like get your hands off
of me
it's so cool this is why I like like I
like Iris in the TV show and Iris in the
in the comics because they're they're
very similar in terms of how they work
and so for the most part when it comes
to the to the Renegades basically
chasing down you know like like Wally
and and Iris and trying to get a hold of
Barry and like the new 52 Wally West and
so on and so forth they start kicking
their powers in play and that's when you
learn that golden glider is not like the
golden glider that we know this version
is a Yellow Lantern and that's awesome
that's that's that's super cool the
other half of this though is that it
does kind of shift up the nature of the
yellow lanterns and it does work because
we've seen that in Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern Corps right like just
because someone is wielding a ring of
Sinestro does not mean they have to be a
villain this is not uncharted waters the
other problem with this though when it
comes to Wally is that while this is
going on he keeps getting these memory
Feats that are fed in just these
memories that keep coming back and
coming back and coming back and that's
something that I want you to notice here
they're coming at faster intervals now
it may just be the manner in which
Williamson's been telling these stories
and the way the stories are being told
in like Titans but the general gist was
that classic Wally West came back and DC
Universe rebirth number one and then he
would get a jolt of a memory and then it
would be like one or two story arcs and
then he would get another one and then
it'd be another one or two story arcs
and then he would get another one now
it's he gets one and then bam you know a
couple minutes later he gets one and
then a couple of minutes later he gets
one they're coming back faster and
faster and what this means is that all
these memories of Wally are just pouring
into his mind and so from there what
happens is basically Commander Cole
stops everything he's like look
something's going on here but our orders
are to get Iris West bring her to the
Future put her on trial for taking out
eobard Thon and so because of this like
Commander cold is is no pun intended
he's kind of cold here you know in the
sense that he's like hey look you know
we'll help Wally but like you need to
come with us you don't come with us
while he doesn't get any help so you
know make your decision and it's kind of
crazy here because ultimately like they
end up just kind of going along you know
all the speedsters end up going with
them because they don't really trust the
Renegades they don't know anything about
him it's this group that looks like the
Rogues that appears from a temporal
portal and says you gotta come with us
you have to believe us we're good guys
there's no reason to believe him and so
classic Wally Berry you know New 52
Wally West and they all basically travel
with Iris and the Renegades to jump into
the 25th Century the problem with this
is that when they get there everybody
arrives except for classic Wally and
what we end up finding out is somebody
screwed with the the temporal device of
Captain Cold so that Wally would be lost
in transit and so what we end up doing
is transitioning over to Wally himself
in what really looks kind of like a
broken remnant of The Flash Museum and
as he goes through there he basically
starts getting these words from this guy
and he says like this is your life this
is the Museum of your life this is
everything you've lost and this is when
we start getting like these amazing
Easter eggs like showing Wally West when
he was Kid Flash showing his first
encounter with impulse showing Max
Mercury but once he goes through here
like this person says like this is your
entire life this is everything you know
giant Iris West the children of Wally
are here they're shown in kind of like a
video feed of sorts and so when the
question is like who are you what is
going on here what we end up getting is
the return of Hunter zolomon and Hunter
zolomon is amazing okay so eobard Thon
the the original reverse flash he goes
all the way back to the 1970s right like
he's prices on infiniters once Chrysler
infinitas happened in 1985 1986 then we
got like a new version of eobardathon
and then following that version of
eobard Thon Jeff Johns took over the
flash story and he gave us another
reverse flash named Hunter zolomon now
the difference between eobard Thon and
Hunter zolomon is that where iobarthon
was originally just like a massive fan
of The Flash and then was obsessed with
very made himself look like Barry and
then traveled back into the past only to
find out uh you know Barry had died and
then looked through the flash Museum and
realized he was destined to become his
mortal enemy and went insane Hunter
zolomon was totally different Hunter
zolomon was basically a guy who was just
in the wrong place at the wrong time he
had a really really crappy upbringing he
was involved in a conflict lost the use
of his legs but he was a huge he would
he I would say he worked alongside the
flash more so than anything else worked
alongside Barry as like a criminal
profiler the way he ended up becoming a
villain was because once he basically
lost everything that mattered to him he
basically went to The Flash and said
like help me run back in time use your
Cosmic treadmill help me run back in
time and fix everything that went wrong
and like the flash said no and so so
because of that Hunter zolomon's heart
was just filled with anger and Wrath of
the fact that the flashes wanted to hog
all his power to himself and so he
basically found a way to copy the powers
of the Flash and he's been a villain
ever since but there's like history
there and that's why Hunter's almond
says we were friends once because they
were they were very good friends once
they worked alongside each other the
relationship between Hunter zolomon and
and Wally West is like the rebirth
equivalent of August heart and Barry
Allen in the sense that August heart
became godspeed because of the fact that
he was driven by a desire to kind of fix
everything Hunter zolomon's motivations
were a little bit different but the
pre-villainous nature I guess the
pre-villainous relationship between
himself and Wally was almost completely
identical now Hunter's idea is you have
to destroy the speed force now we don't
know what effect that'll have we don't
know if destroying the speed force will
lead to like the deaths of Jay Garrick
and Max Mercury and Johnny and Jesse
Chambers and like giant Iris West and
like you know impulse like all these
characters we don't know if that's going
to be the case instead all we know is
that like this speed force would be
destroyed but that's the question what
lengths is Wally willing to go to to not
only bring back all the speedsters who
were there at least presumably do that
but also basically go back and like
return things to the way that they're
supposed to be but it's kind of cool
here because remember Barry Allen tried
this during the events of Flashpoint and
that's what screwed everything up
okay so we are picking up with flash War
part two okay flash War part two is
amazing dude okay you didn't do flashes
on me I really wish Joshua Williams had
been a Denver Comic-Con because I got to
see everybody else I got to see him Sam
Humphreys and hang out with him do you
have man I love Sam Humphrey's ready
he's like one of my one of my top five
favorite writers like I'll read anything
the guy right but uh but anyway okay so
flash war is basically kind of like
wrapping up the whole thing with Wally
West right like we talked about that in
the first video that in DC Universe
rebirth number one Barry Allen had
essentially pulled Wally West out of the
speed force and then Wally's just kind
of been free-floating ever since like
he's been in a couple Flash stories he's
been on the been part of the main Titans
roster but that's really it like the
whole idea of like what's going on with
him behind the scenes and how it ties
into all the different aspects of The
Flash Mythos that have basically been
missing throughout all this time none of
those questions were really answered and
Flash War gives us this specifically
this story opens up with Jai and Ira I
always thought it was Iris West and I
feel like it was Iris West at one point
and then it was changed and I wouldn't
say somebody mentioned that at Denver
Comic Con that it was Iris West before
um before Jeff Johns wrote Infinite
Crisis and then it was Ira afterwards
although I'm not going to swear to that
the cool thing about this is remember
when it came to jai or when it came to
the kids of Wally West a lot of the
lessons he imparted on them were part
and parcel to what happened with impulse
with Bart Elm and the reason why was
because after Barry Allen died and
crisis on infinite Nursery at least was
believed to have been dead Wally West
became the new Flash and the idea of DC
at the time was well let's just give him
a new Kid Flash like it makes the most
sense so they grabbed Bart Allen from
the future they said that his speed
force Powers were running out of control
he didn't really know how to contain
them and so they brought him to the 20th
century they handed him over to Wally
teach him how to control his powers
Wally didn't know how he was like I mean
I guess I can but I'm not really a
teacher I can impart what Pearls of
Wisdom I gained from Barry but I'm not
really a teacher in this regard I'm not
that familiar with the speed force and
now those things change with stories
like terminal velocity but what ended up
happening was Bart Allen was handed over
to uh to Max Mercury who trained him but
the idea of of Wally helping to kind of
get impulse's powers in check which is
to say putting him in a position to
where his his speed force abilities are
stabilized and they're not accelerating
his aging is basically what was imparted
to to to the kids of Wally it was
sitting down and saying they had the
exact same problem that's kind of where
this comes from the issue with this is
that Wally didn't remember him when
Wally came back he did not remember his
kids and that's kind of the crazy thing
is that it was a it was a little
piecemeal now in reality I'd say this is
Joshua Williamson kind of going through
and doing it in stages right like if
Wally had come back in DC Universe
rebirth number one and then it turned
into where Wally West's kids and then it
turned into like the whole thing with
Linda Park then like basically the whole
concept of Wally would have been fleshed
out in six months and there would have
been no real storytelling to give after
that instead what DC is doing here is
they're staging it out they're saying
here's Wally when he comes back and then
here's a couple things here and there
and then here's Wally whistling part of
his past and then here's a couple things
here and there and then here's flash War
we basically get the whole kitten
caboodle and so it's cool for what it is
because what we end up knowing here at
least what we're kind of told here is
that a lot of this centers around Hunter
zolomon I remember in the last video we
talked about this that Hunter zolomon
was Jeff John's reverse flash the thing
here is that what you end up having is
you end up having Wally who kind of
freaks out and attacks uh attacks
Hunters element and when he does he
starts to get these kind a flashback of
memories in the sense that he almost
kind of absorbs memories directly from
Hunter zolomon himself now this is part
and parcel to the powers of Wally West
so back when Wally really became the
flash replace Barry the idea was to make
him different the idea of Wally is to
say okay let's make him interesting and
unique and so Wally has powers and has
abilities that are tied to him that no
one else has for example Wally West
cannot be cut off from the speed force
this is the reason why when DC rebirth
happened Wally West was absorbed into
the speed force as opposed to just kind
of losing his powers and just sort of
being a regular person out there
somewhere Wally main lines it and so
because of that fact like he's wildly
powerful not only that when it comes to
like time travel Barry Allen has to use
a cosmic treadmill he can bounce through
Dimensions he can like you know vibrate
himself from one dimension to the next
but he can't run back and forward
through time of his own volition he has
to use the cosmic treadmill to do it
Wally does not have that limitation he
can run back and forth Through Time Well
actually we'll see how that kind of
plays out here but one of the other big
things that Wally has and this is I
believe a power that was actually given
to people after Wally is he has the
ability to kind of transfer speed force
Power hours to people that would give
them like healing factors different
things like that but when he basically
goes to attack Hunter zolomon because
this ability that he has he picks up on
the realization that Hunter doesn't have
his powers anymore and this is kind of
the cool thing is because the way
Williamson writes this it's a bit of a
mystery here we kind of know that Hunter
zolomon's working with eobard Thon but
we don't know how far this goes and
where Hunter zolomon is talking to Wally
what he's doing is saying things like my
powers are gone I don't have my
abilities anymore because of the fact
that my powers are gone it's given me
time to kind of reflect on my life to
reflect the decisions that I've made and
the things that I've done and ultimately
I've I've essentially seen the light
Hunter's element was originally a good
guy he failed to becoming a villain
because he was obsessed with the idea of
fixing his own past his desire to become
a villain was rooted in his own
struggles and strife you know things
that people go through he just took a
different road but Redemption was always
right around the corner for Hunter and
Wally doesn't really know how to take
that but at the same time Wally's also a
good guy and he's like I mean we kind of
have to give him the benefit of the
doubt but more so than any of that
Hunter zolomon knows the location or
claims to know the location of where
Wally's kids are and how to get them and
so the overriding factor here for Wally
is he wants his kids back and so it's
kind of a throwback for the old school
Wally fans all kinds of things go into
this whole ideology and so from here you
really kind of sidetracked for a second
with uh with Barry and with the
Renegades now of course the Renegades
are kind of like this temporal police
force that have been created by uh by
Hunter zolomon himself but there was
kind of a bigger ruse that was going on
we didn't really know what it was all we
knew was that the idea was Iris West was
being taken for the quote unquote murder
of eobard Thon and that was it what you
ended up picking up here with is this
idea that Barry's kind of like look I
need to find Wally West now this is kind
of one of those interesting situations
where you kind of see like Barry and
Wally juxtaposed next to each other and
then you kind of get you know really
kind of you know we kind of I guess come
to this understanding that the story is
what makes the characters interesting
right like Barry Allen in and of himself
is not really interesting to me he's
just a guy who runs really fast Flash
War to me is interesting because it's
about Wally getting his kids back that's
it it's Wally going to every length he
needs to to get his kids back but it's
Wally retreading the water of what Barry
Allen did Barry Allen's just kind of
like running trying to find Wally from
like where in the world is Wally West
and you know you guys the Renegades have
been set up this is all just one great
big huge ruse you guys have been tricked
you don't know it but you guys have been
tricked you know Barry basically grabs
uh you know Commander cult they whisk
over to where Hunter's almond is only
for us to find out that what's actually
going on is Hunter's Alma was the one
pulling the strings that basically sent
like you know the Renegades after Iris
West knowing Wally would follow and with
Wally would come bury now of course with
Hunter zolomon kind of being
incapacitated at the moment and more or
less being defeated the whole conflict
switches to Barry vs Wally and this is
where it really picks up and this is why
I say like like Joshua William said I
think is one of the most prolific
writers in recent years when it comes to
the flash because it's a way to take
these characters who otherwise may not
necessarily have been interesting and
turn them into like wildly interesting
as much as I love Francis manipul's run
at the end of the day it all just kind
of came down to what we got to fight
Gorilla Grodd and gorilla you know
gorilla City and New Iris you know and
that kind of a thing like like with this
it's it's Wally legitimately on the hunt
for his kids and it's kind of cool
because you can look at this and you can
say like I understand exactly where
Wally's coming from if I had kids and
then they vanished one day I would go to
the ends of the Earth I would set the
world on fire if it meant that I would
get my kids back I would sacrifice
everyone I would eliminate everything in
my path do whatever I needed to do in
order to get my kids back here and
that's the whole point is that where
Barry's kind of sent directly to Wally
by virtue of Commander Colt using the
flash I guess using the speed force
signature of Wally to kind of create
like a pinpoint more or less where Barry
can be sent to when he finally catches
up with him this turns into like one
somebody did something and screwed up
the timeline so everything starts going
nuts it looks like the actions of Dr
Manhattan if I'm being honest with you
guys and two once Barry catches up to
Wally directly the two of them kind of
engage in this this incredible
conversation because where he's kind of
trying to impart this this little bit of
wisdom right saying hey look take it
from me the guy who trained you you
can't do this kind of thing you can't
just like run around and do crazy
situations and doing these crazy events
because what you're going to do if you
run back in time you don't know what
you're gonna change there's no such
thing really as like alternate realities
doesn't really exist I mean the notion
of DC sitting down and saying like well
there's all these alternate realities
that stem out of a single action it
doesn't really work that way anymore
Flashpoint kind of solidified that and a
few things in rebirth solidify that what
this means is that if Wally goes back
and and let's say like he goes into the
speed force he breaks it he goes in and
like rescues his kids no one knows what
the consequence will be that's the
importance of all this because that's
what Wally's doing Wally's idea is I can
run into the speed force I'll crack it a
little bit but nothing really terrible
is gonna happen but it's like breaking
glass it's only a matter of time before
the whole thing shatters and that's the
whole point is because the the idea
seems to be no one knows exactly what
will happen if the speed force wall is
what holds the Multiverse together and
all does everything all the universe is
just kind of free float into Oblivion if
the destruction of the speed force means
all the speedsters lose their power no
one knows what the consequences of this
will be but for Wally it doesn't matter
he doesn't care what the aftermath of
this will be he's a dad who wants to
find his kids and it's kind of funny
because when you have Barry sitting down
like Wally's idea is look like you were
a mentor once once upon a time but I've
been flashed like I always flash for a
long time I've carved my Niche I know
what I'm about but if you're getting in
my way of finding my finding my kids
you're no friend of mine so I'm gonna
give you a choice you can move out of
the way or I can run you over and that's
what's so cool this is kind of like
Redemption time for Wally West fans
because there's like this amazing stand
enough you know Barry's like well if you
run I'll catch you and while he's like
you can try I can give you a head start
and you still wouldn't catch me and
that's true Wally is faster than Barry
and that's what's so that's what's so
awesome about this is because like you
can try your best you can do anything
you want to do but at the end of the day
if I take off running in that direction
I'll have to stop in order for you to
catch me you're never gonna catch up and
so because that like it's it's awesome
here because Wally just like takes off
and it's kind of interesting the way
that it's drawn you almost see it right
you see like the look of Barry like
please while you don't do it and Wally's
like this is happening and Wally just
bolts he's just like gone and Barry
tries to chase after him and that's
where this ends but it's like it's like
damn man like dude it's so good like
it's so amazing man I love flash Wars so
much it's so badass
okay so we're continuing on with the
flash rebirth and not really flashy well
I guess the flash rebirth but flash
works and the whole idea behind this is
remember for those of you guys who are
just now getting into this flash War
deals with the idea that Wally West
discovered that his kids or at least he
was told that his kids were alive now
again this information really came from
Hunter zolomon who of course as we
talked about in previous videos uh was a
Speedster who basically became an enemy
of the flash uh after he had essentially
lost the use of his legs and wanted to
flash Wally West to go back and change
time so that everything in Hunter's
element's life really hadn't gone awry
and gone terrible but because of the
fact that Wally wouldn't do it Hunter
zolomon became his enemy and so in this
instance Hunter's element it kind of you
know seemingly grabbed them from uh from
the present day brought him to the 25th
Century and said hey just so you know
Wally like your kids are stuck in the
speed force if you go out there and you
destroy the speed force you'll bring
them back like you'll basically bring
your kids back and again it's very much
feeding on like the parental instincts
of of Wally West which is why it works
the problem with this was that Barry was
coming from this from the perspective of
like the events of Flashpoint right like
when Barry had gone back in time tried
to save his mom's life he succeeded but
screwed up the universe in the process
and had to go back in time and let her
die in order to set things back to
normal uh that's the whole perspective
he's coming from here and trying to
impart those Pearls of Wisdom onto Wally
the whole idea of Wally is I've grown
I've grown beyond your Protege I'm not
the little kid who was Kid Flash anymore
I'm an adult now with a family that I
need to go safe and again it works
because what parent wouldn't go to the
ends of the Earth in order to save their
kids the issue with this is when you're
talking about two speedsters of such
incredible ability such incredible speed
running around it's not like they move
in a vacuum right it's not like they
move around and nothing's impacted by
what they do they're running at such a
high velocity around the earth with
Wally running to break the speed force
and Barry chasing him down that they're
literally sending ripples throughout the
entirety of the universe itself the very
fabric of the universe is literally
shaking at the the kind of speed and the
kind of ripples they're putting off on
such a strong level and so when you have
like Amanda Waller Thief Trevor and the
various members of the government
responding to this and trying to find a
way to deal with it their initial
response and says well let's just kind
of use weapons see if we can take him
out using tanks or something like that
and of course that doesn't work and so
you know this is like a little one-page
thing it's not designed to be a great
big huge uh sprawled out event but in
response to this you have Amanda Waller
who tells Steve's Trevor contact your
friends so of course this basically
means the Justice League but the
important thing about this and and the
cool thing with this great big huge
moment is you're talking about two
extremely powerful guys in terms of how
their speed impacts the world around
them but what this is also going to do
is it's really going to kind of
reiterate the status quo in relation to
how fast like Superman is in relation to
these guys and how fast the various
members of the superhero Community are
in terms of the power they possess and
so for Superman and the rest of the
Justice League and really even some of
the Titans show up on the scene and say
hey look like what's going on here
they're basically given the news by
Steve Trevor saying that like Wally
wants to break the speed force Barry's
chasing him down it's creating ripples
throughout the entire fabric of the
universe you guys have to find a way to
stop him and what ends up happening is
Superman immediately takes off after
them and that's kind of the funny thing
because when Superman races off you know
it's basically like hey you guys have to
stop stop you guys have to slow down but
it only lasts for like a fraction of a
second I mean it's it's it is so
astronomically quick and Superman has to
back off because he can't keep up and
that's one of the big things that I want
you guys to really bring from this when
it comes to like status quoes in comic
books they change all the time and so
really it's kind of been one of those
things where for the last I would say
probably about the last 20 years it's
been generally accepted that the flashes
are faster than Superman because of what
use would the flash be if he's not the
fastest man alive he's just a guy that
can run really fast and so because of
this like it really kind of fits into
the status quo now again going all the
way back to like the 40s 50s 60s and
really from the 60s going forward
especially with regards to Barry Allen
really from the mid 50s going forward in
the modern day you're talking about like
The Flash versus Superman those races
are iconic ah but really it wasn't until
recent years within the last 10 20 years
or so that it's kind of been established
the flash is always faster than Superman
because that's just how fast he is but
from there you switch over to Green
Lantern and Green Lantern's response as
well if Superman can't stop him then the
big green wall will bring him to an end
and again they blast right through I
mean they literally like they tear right
through the Green Lantern's wall and
this is a huge moment this is one of the
things that's really really crazy here
because when you're talking about this
much force moving this fast there's very
few things that can stand in the way of
it and this is designed to highlight a
couple of different things while it does
kind of show that that the flashes are
moving exceedingly fast the real big
take away from this is that like Green
Lantern can't stop him Superman can't
catch him if we ran into a situation
where the flash truly decided that he
wanted to be a villain and just unleash
holy hell across the world there
wouldn't really be a whole lot of people
who can stop him like there really
wouldn't be a whole lot of people that
could get in his way and this is really
more I imagine of like Vindication for
Flash fans right like I've been telling
people for years the flash is one of the
strongest characters there is and nobody
ever wanted to believe that's really
where this this kind of fits in here
because you're talking about a person
who's so fast and moving at such an
incredible speed that really people are
just in the way and that's that's really
all it comes down to so again it's a
really interesting moment here but one
of the things to bear in mind is it
really is Barry trying to impart this
wisdom on the wallet that's really what
he's trying to do here I mean you you're
talking about a guy who's been around
for a long time and he was learning how
to be the flash when he first came to
speed and he was understanding what it
meant to be a hero that there would be
times when your moral compass would be
questioned but you always have to do the
right thing Rio Barry had walked those
walk that path he'd walk that road Wally
picked up afterberry you know while he
gained his powers as a little kid and
Barry was imparting all that wisdom on
him when he was a little kid when he was
Kid Flash and then when Barry died
during crisis on infinite Earth or at
least was believed to have died uh Wally
took up the pieces you know he picked up
the pieces took up the mantle and became
the new Flash and he had to discover all
those things on his own but it's not
like there's really a right or a wrong
here it's not even you know it's really
one of those very hairy morally
ambiguous middle grounds it's very much
a gray area because on one half the
speed force being destroyed who knows
what effect it would have on the
Multiverse and so like you're talking
about this idea that like the speed
force could literally destroy the entire
fabric of creation and while Barry's
trying to stop Wally from doing that at
the same time Wally's trying to rescue
his kids and it makes perfect sense you
know speed force and universe be damned
Wally wants to find his kids and it's a
it's a perfect thing it's exactly what
any parent would do and that's why it
makes it so cool and that's one of the
reasons why like looking at this this
whole situation unfolding this is why
Wally West always had his dedicated fan
base here's the reason why fans always
loved Wally because what you're talking
about here is a character that's so
emotional in a lot of ways and is so
grounded and so rooted that was really
the big difference between Barry and
Wally I mean looking back at the earlier
days of comics Barry was very grounded
and he was very tangible you know but
really he was more of like the iconic
superhero he was he was born and bred in
the age of 1950s science fiction meets
superhero themes he was the one that
reinvigorated interest in comic books
you know with DC Showcase number four
and so with that in mind like Wally was
a lot more grounded he was a lot more
tangible Because by the time he became
the new Flash in the mid to late 1980s
it was really a wholly different era of
comics when Stacia died uh Dark Knight
Returns was about to kick off you had
like all these things that have been
going on that it made Heroes a lot
darker and a lot more gritty and a lot
more real world and and realistic and so
those themes were rolled over into the
Wally West Comics that combined with the
fact that everybody loved him from
Justice League Unlimited and all that
kind of all that kind of stuff it
basically meant that you had a recipe
for like everyone's favorite Flash and
so that's why people love Wally so much
but from there you essentially have
Wally who succeeds like literally seems
to break through the speed force and
shatter the speed force in its entirety
the problem with this is that's not what
happens the speed force is not broken
and it's not destroyed the speed force
is still very much there instead what
ends up happening here is Hunter zolomon
essentially appears but after taking out
all the members of the Justice League
and the reason why is because the sky is
kind of shattered it's basically broken
and where the belief is that the speed
force is broken what Hunter's Holloman
says is that's not what's going on here
what's actually going on here is I want
like I basically lied to you and it was
the most predictable outcome there was
really no point where where Joshua
Williams or Williamson believed that we
would believe that Hunter's almond had
become a good guy he's just like that
incorrigible unchangeable villain and so
it was a matter of just kind of seeing
how this situation would play out and
Hunter zolomon's response is you guys
believe there's only the speed force but
that's not true there's the strength
Force there's there's the sage Force
there's all these different forces out
there now this actually makes a whole
lot of sense when you really break it
down and the reason why I say this is
the speed force is the most prominent
Force just because of the fact that
you're talking about like how the how
speedsters draw their power but with
regards to to this whole this whole
concept if speedsters draw their their
super speed from the speed force then
where do you like super strong
characters draw their energy from where
do you like psychic draw their energy
from that's why this works so well it's
shuffling up the status quo it's
changing things up a bit what Joshua
Williamson is doing here is The Flash
equivalent to Jeff Johns expanding on
the Green Lantern court and saying now
there's a Red Lantern core and a
Sinestro core and Black Lanterns or
white lanterns and indigos and blue blue
lanterns and Star Sapphires and all
these kind of things you know that's why
it works is because it's expanding on
this Mythos that could really even go
beyond the flash Mythos itself but at
the moment what Hunter zolomon had been
doing was studying the entire really the
history of like the world you know of
what had been going on over the course
of like decades and decades and decades
running up to the 25th Century and what
this means is that Hunter's almond is
aware of Dr Manhattan he's aware of like
the war that will take place at least it
seems like he is and so his whole
argument is we need like an actual hero
a true hero you guys are not Heroes you
guys are are standing in for Heroes
you're parading around you're not really
solving anything you're just running
around in circles hoping things change
but he's like I basically like the whole
point behind this was to have you guys
smash through this quote-unquote Force
barrier so the speed force is still
there but what you've done is you've now
released the sage force and you've
released the strength force and what it
means is that Hunter's element can now
tap into these things and what that
means now is Hunter zolomon has tele
telepathy and telekinesis Hunter zolomon
has super strength and Hunter zolomon
has super speed he's literally just like
Superman Amplified several times over
with the powers of Martian Manhunter
this guy is a walking talking God on
Earth
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion to flash war and it's
actually pretty cool and it's sort of
interesting there's actually a huge
consequence like well really two big
consequences that come out of this this
whole thing one of which you may or may
not care about the other of which most
of you will be pretty excited about so
it's it's a it's a pretty cool thing
here it's pretty awesome I remember a
little bit of ketchup here basically the
Wally West villain a hunter's almond is
looking to travel into the past and
essentially prevent the loss of his legs
you know basically make his life what he
wanted it to be the problem with this
and what what the way it kind of works
is it's one of those things where like
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
what this means is that along the way of
trying to gain you know trying to trying
to travel into the past and fix his life
more or less Hunter zolomon had
discovered that there was the speed
force which is where speedsters derive
their power from but there was also the
sage force and the strength Force the
sage Force basically being more like a
psychic force and then the the strength
Force being where people draw their
strength from now what Joshua Williamson
hasn't really done here is tie this into
the greater DC Universe and he may not
and what I mean by that is if the speed
force is where speedsters draw their
power from then is the strength Force
where like Superman and like Solomon
Grundy and like you know super strong
characters is that where they draw their
strength from and like all the psychics
some people like that do they draw their
power from the sage force is that how
that works that may or may not be tied
in DC usually keeps things confined to
character-driven Arc so like a Batman
story arc Superman story arc flash story
arc but we don't know if in this
instance these forces will spill over
into the rest of the DC Universe and say
well you know this also affects Superman
and so on and so forth there's no reason
to believe they don't because the speed
force permeates the entirety of reality
but only the speedsters can tap into the
speed force and use speed force powers
and so because of that it's it's it's
kind of interesting it's really a fun
little caveat and so for the most part
it was basically flash or I'm sorry it
was Wally and Barry trying to track down
and trying to stop Hunter's element and
keep him from going crazy the problem is
that with all these new powers there's
really not much that they can do to stop
him now the other thing here is that
because of what he's doing because of
the fact that he basically ran into the
past and started to changing things up
what this meant is that he was
essentially eradicating the 25th Century
where he comes from and that's the
reason why you have like Commander cold
who's from the 25th Century um Iris West
and um and and you know New 52 Wally
West who are just kind of stranded in
this void more or less this what would
be the 20th century 25th Century but
isn't there anymore now the way in which
Hunter Solomon was able to do this was
by manipulating something called hyper
time now the hyper time is a weird idea
a very weird idea in the realm of DC
Comics the best way I know how to say it
so take DC's publishing comic book era
like when they were publishing comic
books between like 1938 when Superman
first showed up in like 1984. basically
what you had is you had like different
Earths quote unquote they were given
like numerical designations so you had
Earth one Earth two or three or four and
the numerical designation was designed
to do nothing more than to basically say
this is a different universe that's all
it was for what DC did is they said
these universes have always existed
Earth 2 is the age of World War II
superheroes you know the Golden Age of
superheroes basically and then Earth s
was where Shazam that's where the whole
Shazam family was and Earth one is all
the superhero stories that involve you
know Barry Allen and that Justice League
team and so on and so forth all that ran
until about 1984 when it became too
convoluted and complicated to understand
for new fans anyway and so DC cut it all
loose they dropped it they canceled all
that stuff with crisis on infinite Earth
and after that they said now there's
only one universe and that ran for about
14 years and the reason why is because
the 1999 Grand Morrison and Mark Wade
had this idea of saying yeah but like we
want the Multiverse back but we can't
really have it back and so what they did
is they created hyper time and Hyper
time was DC's attempt to copy Marvel's
Multiverse in Marvel Comics you only
ever had one universe but then like a
thing would happen where you would
create like a Divergent Universe based
on that so like in the main Marvel
Universe Peter Parker gains the Venom
suit right the Venom Symbian suit and
then in the main Marvel Universe he
travels back to Earth and he meets with
Reed Richards and Reed Richards says
actually that suit that you're wearing
is alive it's a living breathing
organism you should get rid of it and so
Peter goes to a bell tower he starts
ringing the bells the suit hates the
sound all the all the pain and
everything and leave season that
eventually bonds to Eddie Brock thus
Venom is born an alternate reality would
be what if Spider-Man never stopped
being Venom then like that would be an
alternate reality story but that
alternate universe exists because it
branches off of the main Marvel Universe
DC tried to copy that and what they said
is in addition to branching off
sometimes it'll loop back and intersect
with the main or with the main DC
Universe the problem was that it was
actually more complicated than the
Multiverse they had before and it seemed
really really unnecessary and so fans
didn't really like it too much now all
that turned out to be a moot purpose
because in 2006 they brought the
Multiverse back with Infinite Crisis but
it was an attempt to kind of have the
Multiverse without actually having the
Multiverse and so that's kind of what
Joshua Williamson is doing here that
hyper time exists but this is only a
temporary thing because as they're
running through and as they're literally
like racing through and we're seeing
like these different realities these
different universes you know or really
these different points in time where you
have like the flashpoint fight between
uh Barry Allen and eobarthon you've got
Barry dying during crisis on infinite
Earth you have like all these different
eras in in the in history of DC you also
have like giant Iris you really it's
like them as adults in the future and so
it's kind of cool to see this thing
unfold because as they're racing through
they're actually seeing their life the
way it could have been because Hunter
zolomon is changing things as he's
racing through time like the very Act of
doing it is is essentially changing
things here and there not massive things
but things that are small enough that
they could have effects later on they
can basically create Ripple effects all
throughout the time stream they can have
like big ramifications and so it's kind
of cool here because like when they're
going through Hunter's Almonds whole
stances like but I don't understand why
you're trying to stop me though because
Barry did it so why is it okay for Barry
but it's not okay for me you know and
it's interesting because Wally had the
exact same stance you know when Wally
was like I want to go back in time and I
want to stop all this from happening so
I can have giant Iris you now want to
prevent Manhattan or whoever it was from
messing with the time stream so you know
nobody forgets these last 10 years and
I've got my kids and so on so forth and
Barry's like no no you can't do that and
and the way that Barry comes off here
that's kind of the funny thing the way
that Barry comes off here both to Wally
and even Hunter's almond is don't do as
I do do as I say do if you go through
and start changing time you're gonna
screw things up in really bad ways that
you can't can't even really imagine and
when you go back to change it you can
never go back to the things the way they
were supposed to be or at least that's
the opinion Barry has of course we know
they were because of what Manhattan did
things didn't but still the fact remains
here that it's interesting because
Hunter's element I mean initially was
not going back in time now he's kind of
gone mad with power so he's like oh
create Universe you know create the
universe to my liking and everything
will be the way I want it to be and it's
kind of it's a little disappointing um I
mean Joshua Williamson is an incredible
writer but it's a little disappointing
because Hunter's ottoman kind of falls
into the cliche villain role like I have
this amazing scheme and this amazing
desire and you know it's so human
because all I want to do is just change
my past and keep crappy things from
happening to me but now I've got all
this power I'm gonna remake reality in
my image and it's just kind of like okay
I understand but like I kind of like yes
it seems a little cliche but even then
like it's still a cool idea it's one of
the reasons why Joshua Williamson's
flash riding is so awesome because by
and large the characters are so human
and so solid in terms of how they're
being written and how they're being you
know how they're being given to us and
so the fight here is actually pretty
awesome it's basically a Speedster fight
but as they're going through and as
they're literally facing off again each
other what ends up happening is that
it's kind of hard to explain when you
have Wally fighting against Hunter's
almond he almost creates like these
speed force constructs now when I say
creates create speed force constructs I
don't mean like creating like speed
Force lightning or something like that
what I mean is actually creating what
are essentially flash equivalent of like
Green Lantern hard light constructs and
these come in the form of like Jay
Garrick and Jai and Iris and like Max
Mercury and it's just like these
speechers we haven't seen in forever
because it's kind of like you know my
family runs with me that kind of a thing
and so that's that's why these moments
are awesome that's why these things are
so important is because this is like a
like a one little moment thing and like
when the story ends it could be like in
the next in the next issue Barry's kind
of like so let's talk about those
constructs you made Wally and it's like
yeah man I have no idea what that was or
how that works but like we should try it
again and suddenly he's like sending
people after you know sending you know
speed force constructs after people but
more so than that it's kind of Joshua
Williamson's tribute to like the speed
to the to the The Flash Mythos because
if you're somebody who picked up with a
flash in DC rebirth and never read
anything before then flash fans will
tell you you're really missing out
because p people who sit down who have
been reading the flash for years and
years and years and years running all
the way back to like Jeff John's flash
rebirth the original flash rebirth and
even before that they look at people
like Max Mercury they look at impulse
part Al and they look at Jay Garrick
these different members of The Flash
family and it's like but it's not a
complete family yet because all you have
really right now is Wally and Barry and
New 52 Wally and that's really about it
this cohesive family unit of flashes
doesn't really exist or at least it's
not there right now and so it kind of
leaves people wanting to see that return
and so for people you know who are
looking at this as kind of a small
glimpse of how things could be where all
these different speeches are going to
start making their return and so it's
it's kind of a it's a really good sort
of feel-good moment you know it kind of
hits people right in the fields you know
with regards to how they feel about the
flash Mythos and the speechers they want
to see return and all that kind of good
stuff and so essentially what ends up
happening is you you basically have in
the aftermath of all of all this because
of what's happened with with Hunter's
almond the speed force has in fact been
broken and the result here is that while
spacers can still tap into the speed
force what it means is that with it
being fractured there's no means to
travel back and forth through time
basically hyper time's gone it's
destroyed time travel is destroyed like
like speedsters cannot run back and
forth through time now this is with
regards to speedsters and that's why
like the sage and strength Force are two
distinctly different things because when
it comes to speedsters traveling like
running back and forth Through Time
originally that all started with Barry
Allen's ability to like vibrate through
dimensional walls right like to drive to
vibrate through these sort of universal
barriers that separated one Universe
from another now that went away after
Christ's son infinite Earth and because
that went away the question was well
what's Wally's ability going to be
what's going to make him unique in
comparison to everybody else well just
let him be so fast he can run back and
forth through time well I just just have
that be the case for Wally for Wally
West which was that was his thing like
he was able to Mainline the speed force
and by doing so run back and forth
through time there he had to use a
cosmic treadmill to do that even before
he died when you're talking about this
it basically means that like the ability
to move back and forth from one point in
time to another to change history
doesn't exist anymore for the speedsters
now initially kind of seems like okay
well that's that's cool I guess but
that's a pretty big moment actually it's
a pretty significant thing because what
it means is no more flash points what's
going to happen at least as far as
Joshua Williamson's writing goes is from
the time he's from from this point until
the time he stops writing then there
will never be an instance of time travel
it'll never be an instance where they
will run back into the past and quote
unquote fix things and that's actually a
genius idea because a problem with time
travel because business was really
really guilty of this back in the day
but the problem with time travel is it's
basically used by Riders to write
themselves out of a hole it's like well
I mean I have this really cool story and
like you know it was it was awesome up
until the end but I don't know how to
fix it so time travel and they just jump
back into the past but with with hybrid
time with the inability of flash is
being able to travel back and forth
Through Time what it means is that
Joshua Williams is basically telling us
as long as I'm riding the flash
consequences are consequences when
something happens that thing is
happening now after Joshua Williamson
leaves then it could very well be that
well you know somebody will use time
travel and fix things and so on and so
forth that's the nature of writers
writers just kind of Bend stories to
their own whim and write whatever
stories they want so long as you know
editorial is okay with it and fans don't
give them too much hate but still that's
really kind of the big thing here but
the big moment the big takeaway from all
of this is that as a direct result of
the actions of essentially breaking the
speed force a Speedster has returned
another Speedster has popped up and this
Speedster is Bart Allen also known as
impulse not Bart horror not the crazy
religious guy from the future but the
original Bart Allen and this is a huge
moment now if you want to know more
about Bar Allen check out my video down
in the description I have a video on
BART Allen explain where we run over his
whole character but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to Comics
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah let me know what
you guys think about the story and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]